collège Reny Cassin Paris 10e une classe
de 6e
divers pays leçon du jour la Déclaration
des Droits de
l'Enfant
des less sont
lesêm
ilud ils sont pas comme nous parce que
nous on a des choses essentielles qu'il
faut dans la vie quoi et eu ils l'ont
pas par exemple à nourriture et l'eau
au Portugal il y a des il y a des
enfants qui qui travaillent pour donner
de l'argent à ses parents pour la ha par
exemple comment ça se passe quand à
l'école il faer il y a des enfants en
France qui sont battu et est malheureux
il y en a certains qui ont pas l'amour
dont nos parents nous
donnent je regardais le journal et puis
on disait que les devaient manger froid
parce que leurs parents n'avaient pas
payé la
cantine moi je pense qu'il faudrait
fasse une association pour réunir
beaucoup d'argent dans toute la France
et puis comme ça on pourra acheter des
billets comme ça ils pourront partir
d'autres pays où il y a la
[Musique]
PAI